good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday hope
everyone had an amazing weekend i am
delighted overjoyed and
ecstatic to be sitting here with my girl
original recipe morning toast happy
monday [__] original recipe hey
claude it's so great to see you i feel
like we're really getting back into a
schedule and i actually have some
programming news that i'd like to share
with the class because even though like
it's huge but people there will be a
group of people who are
utterly disappointed there will be but
claudia put out the schedule for this
week of the toast we're only doing shows
monday tuesday wednesday because your
girl is performing at msg on thursday
we'll talk about that we'll talk about
that in a little bit and ben was
supposed to be here tomorrow but i
realized tonight is the met gala your
girl me needs to be here tomorrow to
break down the fashion hogwash that
we're about to see obviously so jackie
is here monday she's here tuesday wait
oh she's here wednesday
so three episodes jackie's here and yes
apologies for the
the bend stands for the bend stands but
also for the short week but for those
who may not know thursday is my final
show of this tour and it's in new york
it's at madison square garden theater
and it's going to be sickening so i'm
not going to do a show the day of
obviously i like really need to prepare
and then the next day like i will be
hungover into oblivion so i just don't
think it's wise to no you need you don't
perform at msg and then like go back to
your podcast next day no i'm too good
for this podcast
i'm kidding you need to decompress it's
also snitch's birthday it's just like a
big weekend there's no way that you
would be performing like it's just not
happening so also for me that works
three days on two days off
and i'm just so excited to see the show
it's gonna be an mno for me it's really
my first like big night out we had a
little girly dinner on saturday night i
got out of the house and we just went to
dinner and it was so stunning so nice
and you had a glass of wine i had a
glass of wine really nursed it i was
really just like there to stuff my face
though because i haven't i went to a
restaurant a few weeks ago but before
that i haven't been to a restaurant
since september and like i miss
restaurant food like i miss getting
something right when it comes out of the
kitchen not when it was biked up right
40 minutes and delivered to me later as
a piece of slop no and it's like a
gorgeous choreography like there's bread
we were at a mediterranean restaurant
there was humus then there was the
appetizers then there was the entrees
then there was a complimentary dessert
that was really [__] good so it was a
cacophony uh
a symphony right so i really missed the
food of dining out so i was just
immensely enjoying and it was a great
night a great like dipping my toe back
in right to the social scene of new york
city social scene it felt really good to
be out but i was exhausted when you got
home when i got home so
who even knows what thursday night has
in store for me it's going to be a
marathon unwell unwell i just twisted
the lv breast pump um which
on
oh my god no i wouldn't oh i was going
to slap you upside the head i'm like you
are out of control
it's a brand e-l-v-i-e-e oh okay okay
okay dying no this [__] i wouldn't put
it past you like no if they made one
yeah who else but me would buy it no the
ld so remember how i had to bring like
my whole machine in here the other way
this one is just like two little things
that you like sticking your body like i
could be pumping right now oh you
wouldn't even know so i think if it
comes in time like that's what i would
bring to the show you could pump
backstage i could pump backstage but i
also don't want to bring my briefcase
with me no no no no no no you can't
bring your briefcase with you but i did
tell you you should leave a pump at the
studio yeah
yeah in the fridge yeah i could do that
too uh but let's i'm to see how this
goes
and that way i could have more longevity
okay also if you give me enough time i
can order a pump on amazon and have it
in the dressing room so you could just
like have it there that's so nice and so
i could i'll figure it out don't worry
about me you have enough on your plate
no i'm so excited i'm also doing a show
wednesday night at like a smaller venue
chelsea music hall just because i've
been off the road for like three weeks i
got a you know you're a little rested
i'm a little rusty and there's a bunch
of toasters who couldn't make it
thursday night so now we're doing
wednesday night small little show
chelsea music hall it's sold out i
apologize for like bringing it up um so
i'm excited it's like a big week you
know
it's a lot it's like a big week it's big
week it's my show it's snatchers
birthday i just have like so many social
events i was added to then it's mother's
day like is everyone else feeling like
it's been so
oh my god my eye does not stop twitching
like
48 hours like kyle from summer house but
i'm really not stressed i'm actually
feeling quite good honestly maybe it's
subconscious it's your subconscious
saying we're stressed it was happening
to me in my sleep last night speaking of
things that happened to me in my sleep
last night i want to shout out to
everyone in new york city who presumed
we were under attack in the middle of
the night last night because there was
the most thunderous
thunder
that ever thundered it was so scary it
didn't sound like traditional thunder it
was not like other thunder so i was like
what is that sound it sounds like a
cannon in the words of luke homes rain
was driving thunder lightning right
exactly speaking of luke copeland blue
comes right now in the transitions i
know the thunder was so scary thunder
from down under uh not as good as that
show waking up in the middle of the
night from the weather elements
but i do am i so bizarre that like i
like when it's
rains on the weekends and it's nice
during the week because i fee
other people are the opposite but like i
during the week like you have to leave
your house you go to work and stuff so i
would like pleasant weather for that yes
but if it's raining on the weekends like
you're kind of forced to stay inside and
have a cozy vibe i completely agree when
it was monday morning and it was raining
i was like darn darn darn no and like in
in my sleep i heard the rain so i'm like
oh sunday night when we wake up it's not
gonna be monday and disgusting outside
i'm like oh this sucks but if i heard
the rain on a saturday night i would be
like this is so cute so cute gorgeous i
agree with you even though like nice
weather on the weekend is nice like for
an al fresco for normal dining for
normal people but i agree completely
okay great also allergy season is here
so make sure to take your allergen and
you know bensoffer is a really big
advocate of walzer do you know what that
is yeah so obviously ben loves a zyrtec
or as he weirdly pronounces it zertek um
but that [__] is like loki expensive and
dwayne reed makes a brand
it's called wall dash dessert it's like
walgreens zyrtec but it's like generic
and it's like so much cheaper and then
that's all been buys so if you're
feeling like you don't want to keep
spending money answer tech check out
walzer oh interesting i think zyrtec is
a good investment because it really does
the job walter is the same chemical
company it's different right i didn't
know about that but like i've never
lamented spending the money on zyrtec
because it's the difference between
being miserable and it's the difference
between life and death 100 yeah uh but
speaking of luke combs yeah stagecoach
happened this weekend and we have to
talk about it we need to just put it out
there so just like get over it so we can
move on from it obviously snatcher was
our correspondent on the ground and if
you're watching her stories like you got
you know the gist of what you were
missing out on and so of course i'm
feeling deep fomo about luke homes i was
watching her stories this morning and as
i've said for months like
that is what i miss most in this world
of like being pregnant it's not that i
miss not drinking it's not that i miss
sushi it's not that i miss this or that
i miss going to a concert specifically
luke homes for rascal flats and just
like having my serotonin levels go
through the roof yeah and even watching
her stories i was just like feeling that
way and i will fly to south carolina to
go to a luke homes concert because he's
not coming back to new york yeah and i
need to see luke homes in the next in
the next three to four months or else i
will spontaneously come by i am so here
for you i will accompany you 100
it was really hard to watch margo's
content and like while i was so happy
for her what you may not know is like
counselor went and my eyes twitching
again because you're stressed i'm not
sure i'm not stressed i'm really i'm not
[__] stressed
um it was hard to see margo go because
margot took um my tickets yeah
that you
thrust upon her that i i literally
i organized these tickets like almost a
year ago like the second that they
announced the lineup i was all over
getting myself good tickets i gave her
my tickets i had searched for homes she
she used one of those homes she took my
car and driver like she took everything
for me and just seeing all of my
planning going into someone else like
having the most amazing time
that was tough she took my parking pass
like it was tough yep you gave her all
those things she didn't ask for them no
i gave them you made the right decision
you know for your career yeah just as an
adult woman and everything that you have
going on up until like a week and a half
ago i was gonna go even though a part of
me knew that like i really shouldn't
right because like you know you're
performing at msg like you can't be you
know and i would be hung over on a
six-hour flight right now getting in at
like 10 p.m with dust in your lungs it's
just not where you're supposed to be no
there will be other stage coaches i know
but like it doesn't feel that way i know
and this one not only was luke combs
everything that you could ever want him
to be but i didn't anticipate how i
would feel about carrie underwood me too
i mean i'm such a carrie gurley i've
always like been a huge fan of her she
has a new song new album i'm listening
to it but i've and i've seen her in
concert but i just didn't
think about what a show-stopping
performance she was going to put on it
you didn't realize the magnitude the
magnitude how i know every song of hers
backwards and forwards how like so many
songs there's so many highs and so many
like you know good lows that's really
anthem have you in your feelings like
see you again you said that she was
crying
something in the water it's just like an
experience a roller coaster of emotions
and i would have absolutely loved to
have been there yeah me too now i would
like to go see carrie on tour i don't
know where she's going i don't know
where she's coming i don't know where
she's going right but i would like to be
there i know she was doing some time in
las vegas because rach parcell took a
girls weekend fun
with her girls and they went to see
carrie underwood because she knows how
to live yeah rachel warcell knows how to
live
maybe that's what's in store for us at
girls weekend or even i was thinking
with haroldson like everything's
difficult even if it was just like a
24-hour girls night yeah i think that's
what rache did 100 i mean rachel's in
utah which is much closer
okay we'll start saving up we'll start
saving up those are my two like big
things that i want to do by the end of
the year i want to see luke homes and i
want to see carrie underwood all right i
can make that happen for you and if the
rascal flats want to uh bring back their
legacy to the rascal flats
yeah because remember they were supposed
to go on tour of course
one last farewell tour before they split
up and kovid ruined it
and that's not right it's so unright
there's nothing like the serotonin
levels at a rascal flats concert i agree
it's a peaceful place it's like really
mixed bag of people but at the end it's
just good-hearted people listening to
good music amazing music so i'm happy
for the snitch it was it was tough it
was tough to watch every morning i was
like all right i had to prepare myself
i'm like let's get through margaret's
stories from last night so i can just
move on with my day especially because
like if we went or if i went this year
like i wouldn't have done it like she
did because she's you know running a
marathon and she's like you know very
strong
i would have just went for the evening
if you had a day in palm springs maybe
hit the spa yeah like have lunch
and then go to the concerts at night so
to everyone who went we're like super
happy for you
um
but other than that carrie underwood
brought out axel rose
oh won't you please take me home
i thought was a great choice because i
imagine there were a lot of you know
big strong men there who were like no
cry pretty really no and like with women
in country like people always like
that's not country even though it like
obviously is so it was like a good [__]
you to those people no it was like like
something for everyone whereas you know
if there had been like uh really
masculine
targeted
headliner i would have hoped that they
would bring out like shania twain or
something right right and um
oh my god my eye
and
he's saying the stepbrothers song
yes
it's so funny how like
[Music]
by the way in the car scene you are the
little son
yeah and i'm derek obviously there's no
one who's more dereky than me it's
actually funny how like that song is
like the one like probably the biggest
songs in music history and like now it's
ruined it's no and it's not even known
as like a bop it's known as the song
from step number one and it's like when
you sing it now you sing it badly like
so flat what am i paying 1800 a week for
voice lessons for
so iconic i honestly feel like derek was
misunderstood
you would feel that way because also
1800 is a lot of money for your kid to
be flat no it was his wife and you know
right 1800 and like there's no
improvement
that's just a bad investment that's just
a bad investment yeah um we have an
amazing show for you guys it's monday so
of course we are going to be unburdening
ourselves at the end of the episode and
if you ever want to write in and
unburden yourself with something really
embarrassing that happened to you over
the weekend it's unburdened yourselves
at gmail.com unburden yourselves at
gmail.com did anything embarrassing
happen to you over the weekend great
question you were pounding down the
martinis i was drinking like an animal
sorry on saturday night i was just happy
to be out with my sister jackie of
course um
no nothing embarrassing now that i think
about it yeah
i smoked pot
at the end of the night and i was like
kind of like i don't really love smoking
pot like i get like really like anxious
no there's a time and a place and it's
only at coachella 100 so i was like in
this bar and i was like kind of freaking
out i'm like ben can we please leave
yeah no and then he took me home and
like we ate diner and then i was
enjoying being high when i was in a safe
space well you can enjoy but that's the
thing about like people are like
high and eating it's like eating is fun
when you're sober too no it's much more
fun when you're high no it's it's the
peak of life when you're like you don't
need to be high to enjoy food no no i do
not need to be high to enjoy food but
it's an added layer of fun okay
um
so yeah that's really what i did this
weekend nothing else except just
preparing them very nice also today is
zack's birthday so happy happy birthday
to my husband even though you're not
going to be watching this and is your
rose your husband
my rose is my husband that's what i
thought okay just double checking
without further ado
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
what did you love i was gonna bother
everyone and where are you i know i was
gonna like ask how do is doing yeah but
we have so much to do today that we have
so much to do and i know do is great
always i know that he's like feeling
really well post surgery like he's come
out the other side yes and so that's
that on that but
one more housekeeping item that we do
need to talk about is your vlog
yes that you put out on friday we need
to talk about it because the boys were
in the background being so [__] cute
i put i begrudgingly put together for
the final episode of the month on
patreon a spring clothing haul because i
did one last year and like i didn't know
if it was going to be well received and
like i think people regard it as like
their favorite episode of all time so i
had recently gotten like so much new
clothing for spring and i was like ugh
like i really should do it even though i
hate the people levels trying on
clothing i was getting so sweaty and
like my apartment was becoming a mess
and like nothing was fitting right so
like it just it's like it's a
it's a stressful situation maybe that's
why i have an eye twitch because of the
stress
um but i put it together and you know
the reviews again are beyond rave so
that's
patreon.com we had five amazing episodes
this month we had the spritz taste test
with jackie we had that spring clothing
haul a bunch of podcasts dear toasters
meet the redheads oh yeah so patreon.com
morning toast if you sign up now you can
get access to all those episodes from
this month and then every episode we've
ever done in the last like three years
so it's a lot it's a lot speaking of the
redheads we're recording the new episode
tomorrow drops on thursday the book is
trash i think we need to talk about
something the redheads choices yeah i
know we're a zero for three yeah and
that's like unacceptable i know but
that's
it's
the blessing and the curse of the
redheads it's like when we all discover
a new book together it's so wonderful
but because no one reads it before and
that's like what's beautiful about it
right it's fresh it could happen where
you know we choose a couple dogs and
that's what's happened now i am the next
choice and i will be choosing a book
that is a bestseller that has i know
kenzie elizabeth already read it and she
said that she really liked it and she
was in a book right like me because
she's actually the only person who reads
more than me so i trust her so i know
what i'm choosing next it says
it if it's bad then i give up yeah okay
you know but it's like
some people i'm sure a lot of people
have already read it that's how much
fanfare there is
okay so i apologize but also as you know
the worse the book the better the
episode 100
um and speaking of 100
i don't know today's episode is brought
to you by peloton peloton has thousands
of live and on-demand classes you can
always keep it fresh
from cycling and strength training to
yoga and running you can experiment new
types of movement judgment-free at a
level and pace that feels good for you
and palestine is great because it can
fit perfectly and seamlessly into your
life maybe you're looking for a 10
minute upper body stretch between calls
or a 40 minute run before bed peloton
works with your schedule whether you
have five minutes or an hour and you'll
never have an awkward encounter in the
locker room ever again so much like
about gym culture is so deeply
uncomfortable and that's why peloton is
the brand for us because you do
everything from your house and we're
quickly turning into agoraphobes and
that's fabulous that works for us i love
my peloton i'll never forget when i
first got a peloton it's like you're
doing a 45-minute spinning class i used
to go to a spin class and it would be an
over an hour endeavor because you have
to get there you have to change right on
the bike like now it's like i have a
hardcore 45 minutes and i'm making the
most of it right these days my favorite
thing to do with my peloton app is to do
the treadmill workouts olivia motto's my
favorite instructor on the treadmill i
just i'm in like a running state of mind
i think it's such a great workout of
course i still love my bike but i love
switching it up also a bike boot camp
cody rigsby does a little mix bite boot
camp so it's on the bike and off the
bike you're working everything to the
soundtrack of little mix it doesn't get
better yeah pellet is known for like
their artist spotlight series and they
have really good music um and right now
is the perfect time to try out peloton
the peloton bike plus is now 500 less
it's the best price yet including free
delivery and setup whoa and there are
more game changing prices available on
the original peloton bike and the
peloton tread hey visit onepeleton.com
to learn more that's o-n-e-peloton
p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com to learn more thank
you paluton for sponsoring
today's episode thank you and if you
want to follow me on peloton and see all
the classes that i do my username is
jackie o w jackie
i'm actually like a peloton influencer
like i don't want to brag or anything
you're like weirdly like such a niche
influencer on random platforms goodreads
and peloton yeah and i'm proud of that
and you should be i think like you know
who's a really big peloton influencer
who teddy mellencamp
oh i could see that she's like you know
fitness queen yeah and she like peloton
last time i like looked at her profile
she peloton she's done like thousands of
classes wow i think i've done like 200
something that's a lot yeah considering
i got it two years ago right
just something cute about me okay let's
get into the stories there's a lot to
discuss and it starts with kim
kardashian and p davidson making their
red carpet debut at the white house
correspondents dinner before we dive in
i just want to say there is a lot of
kardashian news but we have made it one
story and the other four are not
kardashian related other four just pale
in comparison i'm sorry
kim and pete white house correspondents
dindin not only did they walk the red
carpet she posted the photos not only
did she post the photos they look
amazing together i'm obsessed with this
dress yeah and it's very just like
gorgeous period it's like glamorous it's
gorgeous glamorous not like i mean it is
high fashion but it's not like you know
avant-garde we don't understand right
you know it's like
her
wearing black tie okay but i have some
thoughts okay i think like them making
their red hat red house what red carpet
debut at the white house correspondents
center is like
kind of lame
only in the sense that like the met gala
is literally today it was one day's
difference and i just don't understand
it almost felt like intentional like she
didn't want to have the debut at the met
gala right because she went to this
event that like no offense like who
cares right and also it's like she
didn't want to have the debut at the
hulu premiere but why right i feel like
sometimes you just get these ideas into
your head like oh i don't want to make
the hula premiere about my relationship
it was about her relationship anyway at
the hula premiere like where's pete in
the background of all these pictures
yeah they should have done it at the
hula and people were living for it so i
don't think it would have taken away
from the show i think maybe they don't
want to do it at the met because i'm
sure her outfit whatever makes for
itself yeah and it's gonna have to be
stand alone yeah and
maybe they won't even walk together
because it's just like her outfit is so
iconic we also need to talk about the
rumors swirling about that she's wearing
marilyn monroe's happy birthday mr
president right because people are have
been tracking her jet her jet has been
in orlando the the dress is at ripley's
believe it or not she's been to orlando
i think now twice
um yesterday included yes perhaps to
pick up the dress she also said said in
an interview that she would be going to
the met depending on whether or not she
fits into the dress it cannot be altered
this would make sense she cannot alter
this relic and she definitely looks like
she's lost like a lot like a good amount
of weight she looks really small yeah um
but i don't know how she's getting that
ass into that dress i just want to say
like
she like that that ass like marilyn
monroe like actually marijuana was curvy
and i imagine the dress is like a little
bit of elasticity but like that ass is
interplanetary like i don't think you
could just fit into that dress right
which is why it's been up in the air
until now and she really can't do any
alterations i'm imagining that she's
gotten into it because they were there
yesterday that would be really crazy if
she can't go right because she couldn't
get into the dress and i'm sure she knew
exactly what goal she would have to hit
to make it there and i agree she looks
extremely slim and trim but you know how
is that the theme because the theme is
gilded glamour the american lexicon i
mean gilda glamour's like 1800s yes well
it's american
con with american scenic lexicon with a
focus on gilded glamour so yes she's not
dressing like alba vanderbilt but the
dress is guilty of glamour like it is
you know
shy right so she will be in theme and
also like
do you think she's going to do her hair
like well that's what i was going to ask
next time we are going to do a story
about like met predictions later in the
show but i was going to ask do you think
that she's going to go blonde for it or
she's going to do classic kim i think
she's gonna do classic kim because i
think the the message of this outfit is
like kim is the new age marilyn monroe
like she is she is a sex symbol she's
our it girl yeah so i think she's gonna
have to make it her own like what i
don't know what you would consider her
signature hair i would love if she just
did like
long big volume ways i was thinking the
same thing because that's so sickening
yeah and i don't think she's gonna do
like short flan marilyn because then
she's just in cosplay no and like billy
eilish did that literally last year at
the met gala yeah and it's just a
costume at that point i think she needs
to make it her own like hello i'm kim
kardashian the modern male merlin monroe
do you get it yeah
um but back to white house
correspondents dinner i just don't know
why this was the venue of choice because
like it wasn't like a bit she made it
news otherwise i don't think i even
would have known that this event was
going on agreed she made it news and
also like the footage of them like
walking through this conference center
in her sparkly gown it's just like
bizarre like that conference center was
extremely low budget agreed what is kim
doing there no i was like this is giving
bar mitzvah and it was like really not
the vibe for her stunning dress it's not
the vibe stop
so i was confused about that honestly
but of course i was so happy to see them
finally making their debut like him and
his vans like i can't like
he looks really good i mean it's hard to
measure up to kim and it's hard to be
you know her arm candy but she's
obviously influencing him especially
after kanye who was you know who is
fashion
is always trend setting and i thought he
looked very sharp like him and he looked
like himself he didn't look stupid he
didn't look like he was trying to be
someone he's not and i thought they
looked like a very glamorous couple i
agree and
i loved this look for kim because i
think a lot of people like are waiting
for kim in terms of fashion to like fail
in the sense that like you know she's
nothing without kanye and like she was
the muse and and this is just like so
glamorous it's so effortless it's so
fresh fashion delicious that it's like
kim on her own and kim with kanye like
style icon both girls
the red carpet looks from kim have been
really really great ever since those
haven't suffered but i will say some of
the day-to-day looks have
you saw that outfit with the fuzzy
glasses
and the flames
no
hold on
where was she i think she was just like
going to lunch with her sisters
the fuzzy glass no if you oh here it is
i don't know how you missed it let me
see
one second i need to
oh
it's giving diners dragons and dives
it's giving yeah fairy it's it's not
good that's really bad but every it girl
is entitled to you know when you're that
into fashion like sometimes you just
can't see like something is in
avant-garde it's just ugly
so i feel like that was just a classic
case of like is it avant-garde or is it
ugly i mean that's literally horrible
and i'm sorry kanye would never never
the glasses she looks like um
a character on sesame street it's
horrible yeah so i saw that and that was
disheartening everyone's entitled to
make mistakes normalize doing bad at
work sometimes yeah um but i do think
that there is a change without kanye
some good some i think her red carpet
looks have been like so
so glamorous and her red carpet looks
have been more just like
mainstream ready to wear yeah you know
less like okay i need to conceptualize
and understand and have a degree in
fashion history right to like this
senior american lexicon right which is
why i'm excited to see what she wears to
them at tonight if it is marilyn it's
going to be gorgeous no matter what but
like last time she was you know the
definition of i need a degree in fashion
history yeah yeah yeah for sure
now two more things we need to talk
about the kardashians before we go into
the next story the first is
pete was spotted with a new tattoo
and
and it's weird and it's weird so the
tattoo is the letters k
n s c p which everyone has surmised is
kim north saint chicago sam
and i just want to say
i'm just i'm not here for it i'm not
here for it i think it's inappropriate
it's inappropriate i think it's bizarre
it's not appropriate boyfriend behavior
i might even still think it's weird if
they got married unless they were
married for like 50 years but like
i don't know i mean
i've never dated someone with children
so you maybe if someone in the comments
has let me know like i feel like this is
crossing a line i agree i i think once
they're married for 20 years like at the
20-year mark like you could do this yeah
but to be dating for seven months and
also having such
beef with the dad's father
it is
not right to me i just saw it and like
up until this point everything that i
see from them i'm like oh man yeah this
i was like hmm
no interesting not sitting right with me
yes i'm kanye i'm pissed it's
inappropriate it's weird it's too much
but again there's not any like full
confirmation that that's what it is even
though like it obviously what else is it
i don't know it's not the vibe stop i'm
not into it i just want to say even
though like you know i would like blow
smoke up these two's ass like so hard
it's [__] weird yeah agreed too much
too soon too far dial it down agreed
next up in our kardashian subset kylie
jenner shared that she gained 60 pounds
during her pregnancy with baby number
two so kylie posted to her story on
friday a video of herself working out
and she said gain 60 pounds again this
pregnancy i'm down 40 pounds just trying
to be healthy and patient walking slash
pilates is my favorite combo so when i
saw this i was so
shook shook in like such a positive way
like it really resonated with me because
obviously and i spoke i mean i'm
on my own journey postpartum and nobody
really talks numbers 100 and there's
been a few times where like i've wanted
to but i don't you know i don't want to
be toxic or anything you know i'm just
trying to be patient but like it is
helpful to see some other people's
progress other people's progress and
like kylie like she like i mean we've
seen her doing press and stuff and she
looks so amazing and so gorgeous so i've
just been like feeling like oh you know
my snapback is just a little bit slower
but seeing her just like put some
numbers some cold hard numbers to it
just really made me feel
very seen seen i i felt so relatable and
i was like oh i'm okay i'm okay even if
i was like more or less like it's like
okay everybody is just
doing their best and we just have to be
patient yeah and it will come and like
with kylie i think
sometimes it feels like you know because
she doesn't show up she's not on
instagram every single day she'll take
like a month off and then show up
looking snatched and we miss all the
hard work right and so it's easy to feel
like small by that in that sense but
this time around she's been like very
open about her struggle and i think it's
actually um
been so great for a lot of women yeah it
really made me feel really um
like i guess less alone would be the one
that i don't know it just like it it
resonated with me and i think it's like
on instagram it's become like taboo to
talk about yeah because it's like
i guess saying you want to bounce back
is like
toxic diet culture i don't know i can't
really follow like all of the all of the
controversy but like there's always like
drama everyone's always a coming for
everyone when they're talking about
their snapback journey right but like if
you want to snap back like it's a free
country right and it's not just about
like the numbers or just wanting to lose
weight it's just like about being
feeling like yourself you know and like
i have a closet full of clothes that i
can't wear i'm wearing clothes that
aren't you know the things that i would
like want to be wearing yeah and i don't
feel like myself yeah i'm looking
forward to when i can feel like myself
100 so i just thought that was really
cool
to share and also it does feel like
especially with like celebrities models
you know all these people it feels like
everyone like gets pregnant has just
like a belly gives birth and then like
the basketball you know and so when
she's like i gained 60 pounds and i'm
like oh okay so did i
no i but also like i'm
a lot shorter than her so it's like not
comparable but you know i didn't just
gain a belly i ate no legs i gained arms
no you didn't just well how big was
harry seven pounds 14 ounces you didn't
gain seven pounds no exactly so i just
for all of our postpartum mamas out
there i just you know hope that
we're all just like okay yeah you know
totally she's really becoming like a
post-partum relatable queen i'm living
for it and i'm just so glad
to be postpartum i know that you're like
so happy to be alive in the time of uber
like i'm so
happy to be postpartum in the time of
kylie i hear you especially when she's
sharing like she is so deep yeah
yeah so that was pretty cool
it's pretty cool are you ready for our
next story excuse me
a little publishing news okay magazine
it ends their weekly publication
becoming the first celeb title to tumble
now this is like half the story okay
magazine is stopping their print
magazine
after 17 years they will be going fully
online they will continue to publish
occasional special issues and their
website which is owned by a different
company from the print edition and will
stay online you know it does feel that
way now that they say that like i do
feel like okay magazine.com is so
different from what you see in the
airport yeah i mean they're both like
tabloid trash
but
actually i'm not really seeing what
you're seeing how do you feel they're
different like when you see the magazine
in the airport it's like
kim and pete are married secretly right
right and then when you go to their
website it's like stassi shorter opens
up yeah it's like a classic
internet just like a conglomerate
content
uh curator curator yeah no but in but
they don't have if you go to okay
magazine.com it's not like brad and jen
are getting back together that's true
it's not like the typical tabloid that
we know yeah their website is very
wholesome yeah you know like theresa
judah shares her favorite recipes yeah
totally so it does feel like they're
separate but it does feel like the end
of an era like for as long as i can
remember especially as a kid like
i'm always purchasing like a million
magazines before a flight because i like
to do the crossword puzzles and i just
like to look at the pictures so this is
truly the end of an era and i don't know
is in touch next life and style yeah i
don't know it will be it will be weird
not to see those girlies up on the shelf
i know
but
times change right and i think this is
indicative of how like we're consuming
differently yeah i mean of course like
we're all online but i do also think
less people are falling for like brad
and jen are getting back together right
right you know yeah and i think it's
high time like these out of control
tabloids with like their actual
fallacies
have real consequences i'm surprised
they even made it this far i'm actually
starting to feel like these magazines
are like a front business because i
don't know who the [__] is buying them i
don't know but someone has to be buying
them because they're sold everywhere i
know like newsstands
um
grocery stores airports like they're
everywhere so there is a market for it
no you guys who's buying these magazines
because not only like is everything a
lie
but you can get it on your phone so i i
do buy for free i do buy magazines when
i'm in a i buy magazines at the airport
but i don't buy in touch star i do no i
buy people because they have the best
crossword and because like you'll get
some heartwarming stories you know i
always buy people but i'll give them an
interest i'll grab two or three other
ones for another crossword puzzle and
just for pictures i'm not reading it and
being like oh my god brad and jen are
getting back together i'm reading it
like oh keep picture of jen i like her
hair you know you didn't already see it
like no scrolling maybe but it doesn't
bother me like on a plane i'm desperate
you know yeah
i'm desperate but i i do have
a a bar
and it doesn't meet that bar well it's
truly the end of an era
yes
though it's not really going to change
the magazine landscape because there are
so many other ones that will be on the
shelves you won't even notice it's gone
no 100
are you ready for our next story
yeah elizabeth moss is calling
scientology quote misunderstood
scientologist elizabeth moss thinks that
people have the wrong idea about the
highly controversial religion she said
it's not really a closed off religion
it's a place that is very open to like
welcoming in somebody who wants to learn
more about it i don't think i think
that's the thing that is probably the
most misunderstood right no no i don't
think we're all against scientology
because we feel they're closed off
yeah no she did an interview with the
new yorker which was published on friday
friday she said that she can't control
how the public perceives scientology and
that she can only share her own
experience she said people can obviously
hold in their mind whatever they want to
and i can't control that if it's not
that it's going to be something else
i mean it's high time she is like
addressing this because as much as
handmaid's tale is like a great show
it's unbelievably weird the similarities
between uh
the
guild what's it called like the
i don't know
the gildan
the glado
whatever yeah yeah yeah like that's what
the government is called in like this
new america in handmaid's tale the
gildan or something
and
a lot of the practices are eerily
similar to just like the vibe of
scientology like you can't really leave
they kill yeah gilead gilead they're
like you know it's so it's
even though she's giving nothing in this
interview it's high time somebody asks
these [__] questions because it's
weird and as claudia would say it's high
time it's high [__] time the
time is high but i'm whole
dead on
i'm gonna be your
number one
i'm not the kind of girl who gives up
just
like that
oh no
i have a different song which is why i
couldn't join you because i needed to
keep it in my head
[Music]
i know what you're singing but those
notes i think it was good casey neistat
it's probably more like this
it's hot
[Music]
that's a cute song it is a cute song and
it is high time a time of the [__]
time that elizabeth moss addresses us i
had to stop watching handmaid's tale
because it was so terrorizing and i'm
thinking to myself like i'm in control
of my own life i can stop watching this
show
and then i decided to do that sometimes
you always have to do that with books
but it's harder because then you don't
get to check it off on goodreads
but no one's tracking which shows you
didn't right no and it's just um maybe i
should read handmaid's tale but again
like why it's so upsetting like it's
really really considerate maybe not then
especially about like babies it's like
all about babies
maybe not yeah maybe not so like i said
it's high time even though she really
said a lot of nothing um
and also she was asked like about the
moment i guess at like the sag awards a
few years ago where leah remini won and
she for those who don't know leah remy
is like a very outspoken ex
scientologist she has a tv show a
podcast everything um elizabeth moss was
seen like leaving the room and she said
oh that was nothing i was just going to
the bathroom lies
drama lies i'm going to like watch
someone you don't like get an award
right grow up
um i just like
not to be like you know against women i
kind of hate elizabeth moss i see that
for you she's just not my favorite i
wouldn't think that she would be no not
especially like after mad men peggy's
she was like such a um
she was like a girl boss but like in the
most annoying way yeah
yeah she grew boss a little too close to
the sun for sure for sure when she
started stealing clients from dawn like
who do you think you are he like
invented you totally are you ready for
our next story a little food news that
looks so delicious is it the food news
that's brought to you by relief band yes
one in three minutes too many of these
and you're gonna need your relief did
you guys know that one out of three
americans regularly suffer from nausea
you're looking at one yeah you're
looking right at her and you've got to
check out relief band the number one fda
cleared anti-nausea wristband that has
been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness anxiety migraines hangovers
morning sickness chemotherapy and so
much more how it works is that uh the
wristband on your wrist will stimulate a
nerve that travels to the part of the
brain that can controls nausea
then it blocks the signal your brain is
sending to your stomach to tell you that
you're sick
um it's really
kind of crazy how fast and effectively
this works i know you get sick in cars i
have a lot of nausea when i get
migraines or when i'm hungover and it's
just like the easiest thing you slap it
on and your problems are solved
and it's just something you should
really always have with you when you're
traveling if you're doing like a long
car ride you get nauseous on your phone
throw a relief band in your purse don't
wait till you need a relief band just
have one yes
do not let the fear of nausea prevent
you from being present in life's moments
right now you can join the over a
hundred thousand relief ban users with
our exclusive uh offer just for morning
toast listeners
also the product is a hundred percent
drug free non-drowsy and it provides
all-natural long-lasting relief with
zero side effects for as long as needed
so if you go to reliefband.com and use
the promo code toast you'll receive 20
off plus free shipping with a no
questions asked 30 day money back
guarantee remember it's better to have a
relief band and not need it than to need
it and not have it
truer words put that on ancient proverbs
put that on the canva pro card next
so head to
r-e-l-i-e-f band dot com and use our
promo code toast for 20 off plus free
shipping wow my eye twitch was out of
control during that ad because it was
stressful thinking about not having a
relief it's true it's true
okay next up some food news that sounds
quite delicious krispy kreme is
partnering with cinnamon toast crunch
again for new cinnamon milk glazed
donuts look at these bad boys love love
love and you know what i love i love
stories about krispy kreme because
obviously someone who works for krispy
kreme is a toaster and somehow every
time we talk about it the next day boom
right outside our door donuts that's why
we do what we do you guys yeah that's
why we're going to start doing a weekly
food news session i mean we already do a
food news but i do feel like if it's not
for us who's going to tell you about
these amazing collaborations that are
out there it's true there's no other
show that's dedicated not letting you
know who's syncing up and giving you
deliciousness not even show because when
you were gone and i was like looking for
stories on one day i was like
particularly bleak and then i was
remembering how we just did that kitkat
blueberry muffin thing i'm like oh let
me find some like food news and i
literally googled food news and i got
like delish.com and bon appetit like
recipes i was like no give me like a an
e online for food yeah doesn't exist
yeah who's tracking these industry
breaking collaborations if i am not for
myself then who will be
that's a great question canva pro put it
on
anyways the new krispy kreme donuts are
available for a limited time they
feature a cereal milk glaze made with
cinnamon toast crunch so there's two
donuts one that's just like classic
glazed a ctc vibe and the other that's
like topped with real cinnamon toast
crunch i think this is an amazing
partnership what was the last krispy
kreme partnership that we tried or we
were just talking about krispy kreme no
they're remember we did a mukbang oh was
it oreo yeah oh
yeah obvious though yeah this seems
obvious because they had a big oreo and
it looked kind of disgusting yeah but
they were really good we tried them and
this sounds like an obvious
collaboration as well but cinnamon toast
crunch is [__] fire like it's one of
the best cereals and to make it into a
dessert
i love chef's kiss compliments to the
chef compliments of krispy kreme for
like every time they're in the news like
remember when they were giving free
donuts to everyone who got vaccinated
and then everyone was like you really
shouldn't be doing that big yikes um i
think they're always in the news and
like
gotta meet the ceo
totally and just you know our address
hasn't changed so feel free to drop them
over tomorrow is good as we recap them
at gala wednesday two wednesday two but
no we're not here thursday so they'll go
bad right right so only tomorrow or
wednesday if you want to deliver the
donuts just double double checking
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
no
yes
it's the final story
[Music]
dms
pete that's a weird tattoo
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay our fifth and final story is a
little
met gala pro game what are we e like
lead up to the red carpet oh yes six
hour pre-show well who's going to be
wearing what who's going to be there
here's what we need to debrief before
because it's a lot it's overwhelming
yeah so here's what we know so far about
met gala 22 the theme the guest list
chloe has already been spotted in new
york walking into the hotel
travis and courtney are here i just want
to say that doesn't mean anything
because last year travis and courtney
were there at the hotel in the mark also
yeah they were in new york but they
didn't go but there was a big rumor that
the whole family is invited this year
yes i mean minus rob minus rob obviously
yeah yeah and caitlyn right fashion's
biggest night of the year is almost here
after several postponements we will be
back on the first monday in may and
while the uptown ball always delivers
spectacular style statements page six is
guessing celebrities will go especially
big this time around seeing as last
year's event was
not theirs a horrible
catastrophe i know and you know what
like it's last year was like nobody
really understood the theme because it
was american lexicon and even this is
also american lexicon it's the same
theme but like with a different subset
the official theme is in america an
anthology of fashion last 2021 was in
america a lexicon of fashion so they
just went to thesaurus.com and they
changed it it's based on the two-part
exhibition from the museum the second
installation of which will reflect the
evolution of american style and also
explore the work of individual
individual tailors dressmakers and
designers as the costume institute's
head curator andrew bolton told vogue so
who is on the guest list while they do
keep it top secret page six style
exclusively revealed that megan the
stallion will attend this year's gala
wearing moschino katie perry she said
that she will be going and playing a
whole different card this time around so
i imagine something understated so she's
always like the mystery the most literal
burger the lamp
yes
uh beyond that the met gala oh this is
just like
met propaganda about who usually goes
blah blah blah anyways this year the
dress code is all about gilded glamour
as the event will ask its attendees to
embody the grandeur and perhaps the
dichotomy of gilded age new york well
bishop hosting blake lively ryan
reynolds ryan reynolds i love you i love
my favorite dating app
regina king and lynn manuel miranda are
serving as this year's celebrity co-host
tom ford and instagram's adam moseri and
anna wintour will continue their roles
as honorary met gala co-chairs now
here's a question for you if kim is
wearing
marilyn
who is she going with
you know what table is she at
oh it doesn't matter like someone like
who every anyone will have her maybe at
instagram like yeah maybe or maybe they
should they should really just have a
kardashian taste i agree um maybe it's a
skims table
i love that um okay so here's
predictions the mark hotel is like
already popping people have been
standing outside all weekend vanessa
hudgins was out taking pictures in front
of paparazzi she's in town staying at
the mark like i have to assume
that means she's going which i just find
unique that would be the first time for
her i
i imagine i just feel like if you didn't
invite her at her gabriella montez then
you don't deserve her at her at her e
red carpet hosting it yeah no that's a
really good call um so as far as the
kardashians i think it's safe to assume
that they all are going i don't know but
kylie actually was traveling yesterday
kylie's going for sure kyle's going for
sure kendall and kim always go and
courtney and chloe have never been chris
always goes also
um i'm really get a picture
of the six of them on the carpet that
would be so iconic nothing else would
matter i'm really interested to see like
who from the digital space gets invited
because the way that like the oscars
embraced like tick-tockers was so
interesting and i don't think that the
met will do that but last year there was
addison i do think she'll be going
against new york there was emma
chamberlain who's definitely going again
yeah um
there was
who else youtube oh jackie aina nikki
tutorials so they had a bunch of people
but i'm curious if any of the tick
talkers are gonna like break through
charlie dimlio i don't think she's old
enough to go she's 18 now she's in the
bahamas for her birthday so she
obviously chose not to go but i don't
know what that means for dixie i feel
like dixie will go again because she
went last year and she was like
sickening yeah so i hope that she does
go i do hope that they bring some fresh
new talent me too like who am i hoping
to see from
tick tock
like just like obviously addison charlie
like it's so obvious like i would really
like to see
[Music]
i don't know just like a lot of people
yeah i hope they bring some fresh faces
yeah for sure and not everyone just like
who's a youtube input like i'm it's just
those days are kind of over i agree but
also i feel like it's just been the same
people at the met gala for like the last
five years i'm ready for taylor swift
moment and i'm also ready for a beyonce
moment who both haven't shown up in many
years do you think either of them oh
what is her tale what's taylor chatter
saying taylor chatter is saying that
blake and ryan are hosting and the theme
is america and you know miss americana
and the heartbreak prince okay so people
are thinking like it's definitely a
possibility but i don't know if taylor's
at a place where she's just going to an
event
that kim kardashian's also going to
well i feel like she's not gonna not she
shouldn't not go just because kim's
going there like why deny herself a good
time because like she doesn't need it
and also like these events from like
what the insiders say have really become
just like the kardashians are the prom
queens right all about them right
they're like the toast of the town yeah
um i'm trying to think like who's had an
amazing year well the euphoria girlies
we know zendaya is not going but
hopefully sydney sweeney and alexa demi
are going barbie ferreira was there last
year which is just like so weird that
she's like the only
new euphoria girl who's been because
she's like not the most famous
um but she looked great last year with
jonathan simkai
i'm just trying to think like who do you
who do you think is like an it girl of
this year i definitely think sydney
sweeney is like a nick girl oh for sure
let me check who i follow on instagram
yeah that's a good thing and who are my
new followers like oh nicola ann peltz
is my new follow-up oh you think they'll
be going yeah they won last year oh i
love that
[Music]
i hope like i do hope to see them
oh that's a really good call i hope
olivia culpo is going it's her turn oh
my god totally veteran i hope rache
parcell is going uh i hope we're going
i hope we're going okay let's see
i hope honestly like um
we get sophie turner and joe jonas they
haven't really left their house in a
while yeah but they always do go and i
think she's pregnant so actually i don't
think she will be going but everyone's
like loving pregnant fashion these days
i know but like i think she's like i
feel like deep in her oh i would love no
she's in barbados to give birth like
she's not traveling anymore but didn't
she just go back to l.a asap rocky did
because he got arrested i thought he was
she was with him oh maybe but i know she
wants to give birth in right
right right
olivia rodrigo went last year she's
definitely like an it girl
i think she'll be going again do you
think any reality stars would go like
any housewives i mean
honestly do you know who would like kill
it at the maximum yeah yeah but she's
too like low brow yeah even on real
housewives beverly hills
yeah like imagine if someone from like
the bachelor made it to the met gala it
would have to be someone who's really
like done a million other things since
then yeah uh
who would be the closest to
like
tyler cameron honestly tyler cameron
honestly i would love to see paige and
craig
i really would yeah
she could invite a couple reality stars
no she's such a [__] she wouldn't kill
her no god forbid her event is like i
don't know interesting just uh like
one real housewife oh i wonder if we'll
get willow pill who's the most recent
winner of rupaul's drag race simone from
like the winner two years ago has become
like a fashion it girl um and i don't
know maybe we'll see that for willow but
she did just win so i don't know if
that's like too soon lily james oh for
sure she's like definitely having a
moment i'm trying oh yeah especially
like with pam and tommy i'm trying to
think of like shows that
like beth dutton should be there
will she be some of the downton people
should be there too because they're
promoting a movie they might have gone
in the past but because we didn't watch
we didn't we didn't care yeah you know
and maybe like that girl from gilded age
mel streep's daughter
who's meryl streep's daughter
marianne miss
the one the blonde girl yeah
what
right
i don't think so yes i'm telling you i
know meryl streep has a daughter but
that
marion brook yeah mary and brooke hold
on wait my mind is blown right now hold
on maybe i need this i also would love
to see bow and yang
at the met gala
meryl streep is her mom no
what's your name
luisa jacobson
i'm shocked
i'd love to see bow and yellow we'd love
to see i mean i do feel like snl isn't
easy they may be like if people a lot of
droppers know like they can easily
invite cast members yeah yeah yeah
because they're in new york yeah yeah
okay i'm honestly shannon ford should be
going 100 hundred percent now that i'm
looking through i'm following i'm just
like unfollowing people left right and
center
oh you gotta go
goodbye
that's really funny
um like tana mojo should be there you
know no actually like that i don't agree
with she should be there so i'm actually
really really looking forward to it in
the sense like last night i was like i
wish it was tonight like i just want to
keep refreshing my phone and like seeing
people's and you know i'm like really
stressed because usually we're always
breaking the news of like who's wearing
what on the morning chest instagram yeah
we can't do that anymore yeah no we
won't be posting any photos but we will
be doing a whole breakdown recap
tomorrow and i'm really excited i'm
really hopeful and i'm hoping that
the fashion is fresh and they give us
something like i think as a society if
you look around and like even stage
coach coachella like
fashion is in the toilet we are lost i
agree and if anna wintour like she is
supposed to be our fashion steward
arbiter and this is the time pull us out
of this black hole of fashion that we
are in yeah
the and and lead us and show us the way
because and that's what she's supposed
to do it's like the arbiter of fashion
so this is what your time what is your
favorite most recent
um mech gala theme
i loved heavenly bodies that was good i
loved camp like it was
so dumb it was you know it was clown
world it was clown world and i loved
every minute of it because looking camp
right in the eye do you ever see that
meme no
before she left her hotel room she put a
picture on twitter it's her looking into
a compact mirror and like the camera is
getting the mirror so it's her eye and
the caption is looking camp right in the
eye and then she walks out of the hotel
at the mark and like they show a picture
she's literally wearing like a prom
dress like it's so ugly yeah and it's
the best meme of all time i do feel like
camp was really a sign of the times it
was like peak 2019 like everything was
just like the more and more you know and
like everything was people were moving
so fast and quickly and like it was just
very clownish i enjoyed it and also like
the looks that kendall and kylie gave us
like agreed obsessed but you're right
heavenly bodies was great kim's like
gold it's crazy how like it's literally
kim's event and for years she was
literally banned from it but now like if
they don't go it's beyond uninteresting
i guess they are the reality tv stars
there oh
no but that just goes to show so she
should invite some more look how these
girls transformed your event it's true
i'm like so over anna wintour and her
close-mindedness like that but this is
an opportunity for her and not only on
the fashion front like i really do hope
that we get something inspirational and
inspirational but i hope on the guest
list front like i hope we're seeing
people that like she's she could make
anyone scream like she's yeah
no taste maker the most recent show
someone i don't know the most recent one
was like so lame
so especially in terms of the guest list
like honestly the kardashians shouldn't
have even went like that's how lame it
was so so so lame only kim and kendall
and chris went kylie dinko oh yeah and
kendall actually saved the whole party
with that dress what was she wearing
like she was literally looked like a
chandelier oh crystal gorgeous uh
gorgeous that's what
kendall should do
audrey hepburn because that's also like
americana because the theme is the same
right because we're having a redo that's
how terrible it was yeah i'm not
understanding like the same theme but
like with one different word no because
it was terrible terrible um so we will
be recapping the entire met gala
tomorrow i'm so excited to just like sit
on my couch looking fat as [__] eating
chips criticizing other people's looks
that took months and months to prepare
for because that's just a little bit
about me i'm a toxic girly and we are
not done with the show yet even though
those were the past five right we're
done those were the past five i do feel
as though you needed to know them
especially that krispy kreme one and we
are not done because it's unburdened
yourselves time which is brought to you
by all birds all birds creates shoes and
clothing that are better for you better
for the planet and using a revolutionary
roster of premium natural materials it's
like their popular tree runner sneakers
called the tree runner because it's made
from eucalyptus tree fiber which is a
lightweight breathable and silky soft
material making the tree runner
is the perfect everyday shoe for getting
the most out of your sunny days
so they're minimal and versatile for
effortless everyday style everyone loves
all birds if you like to run that's
great for you but if you just need to
wear sneakers like to the airport around
town you want to be comfortable all
birds are fabulous for that as well they
also are great running sneakers that's
what i wear when i run on the treadmill
and they provide a lot of support
they're thoughtfully designed without
any unnecessary frills or logos that
they go with every outfit perfect for
exploring a new city during the day then
exploring a new menu at night spend less
time putting together your outfit and
more time enjoying the sights that is
a slogan i can really get behind i hate
spending time putting an outfit together
find your new favorite shoes for sunny
days and upcoming travel at allbirds.com
that's a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s
dot-com
love it alrighty unburden yourselves is
our weekly segment on mondays where you
can unburden yourselves with
embarrassing things you did over the
weekend if you ever want to write in to
unburden yourself you can do so at
unburdenyourselves
gmail.com that's plural unburden
yourselves
gmail.com
at twitch.com my i just not stopped
twitching
i think i need to take a nap or
something nobody you slept 12 hours no i
know i don't think it was enough
which is like if i'm really oh my god it
doesn't stop
i may need to go to the hospital okay
first up claudia and jackie thank you so
much for taking the time to read this
email i'm a huge fan and i need to
unburden myself immediately last weekend
i met this cute guy a bar and we totally
hit it off fast forward a few hours i'm
at his apartment and it's clear that i'm
about to spend the night at his place
but the huge lingering problem is that i
really had to poop i decided just to
hold it because the bathroom door was
right next to his bed at 3 a.m i
literally jolted up for my sleep sweaty
and turtle heading and it was now or
never do or die my man friend was dead
i don't want to know you know turtle
heading i mean i don't never heard that
before but i can surmise i can and i
don't want to yeah keep going my man
friend was dead asleep so i went to his
bathroom and took the most relieving and
breathtaking poop of my life i went to
flush the toilet and this [__]
would not flush i panicked and took the
plastic packaging of the toilet paper
that was under the sink and put it on
like a glove i dunked my hand into the
toilet to grab the poop i went to throw
it away but he had no trash in his
bathroom i don't know why so i had no
choice but to take the wrapped up poop
and put it in the cabinet under his sink
i climbed back into bed and was so happy
when i saw i was still asleep but i
panicked that ten minutes later i
decided to go back into the bathroom
shove the turd
in my purse
i immediately called an uber and left
the scene of the crime i texted the guy
the next morning he had a great time but
wasn't feeling well giving him some
reason as to why i left let's just say
that even though this man is my soul
mate i will definitely not be seeing him
ever again after this horrendous turn in
the purse incident sincerely the most
unhinged girl you know i just have so
many thoughts like first of all your
first plan was to take it
and put it in the trash can why would
you leave a dump in the trash can he's
gonna wake up and walk into his bathroom
and be like holy [__]
that stink so then you're like oh let me
put it under the cabinet again not
solving your problem you should have
thrown out the window or something yeah
my first question is was there a window
you could like throw it out and he could
think like a bear came through right and
i also need to know like where's the
purse it obviously you have to burn it
right what kind of purse but i do think
that you taking it with you is the best
and not leaving it there but
i mean does he have any idea that this
happened like you could see him again
and then it'll be like a funny story to
tell him like once you're married with
children and like you know locked in
right now
i've heard a lot of stories about girls
who like pick their poop out of the
toilet
you know what actually i don't really
want to go down this road i'm going to
take back what i said thank you for
unburdening yourself yeah um i don't
think it's that bad because you didn't
get caught you did what you had to do
you did
and you didn't get caught which is so
important yeah i think it's fine and i
think you can see him again pending like
you didn't leave any like duty stains
all over the house yeah and if he texts
you then like you're he's fine with it
he's like text you like hey skidmarks
yeah but like if he reaches out
definitely see him again you went all
through it through all right for what
right because if you were never going to
see him again then you could have just
left the turd in the toilet
[Music]
[Laughter]
totally dump and run
um okay i hope you feel better
next up
wow someone is unburdening themselves
from something they did 10 years ago
it's never too late to unburden yourself
i've been carrying this around for 10
years then your new segment on tnn came
along so i'm unburdening myself set it
down my friend my senior year of high
school i fell in love with my english
teacher it's so cliche why is it always
an english teacher but i was a full-on
virgin with no serious intentions of
doing anything but at the same time i
was seriously obsessed with him i
couldn't shake it he was 36
at the time and i used to justify that
for reference i'm 28 now and i would
think that dating someone 36 is way too
old for me anyway i would actually have
sexual dreams about him and he was like
a weirdo like a scruffy older version of
johnny depp in willianka willy wonka but
let's go in the look and more in the
vibe okay i'm here to reveal that we
emailed back and forth my entire
freshman year of college like i would be
be outdrunk and hook up with like a
gross frat boy but also email my teacher
on the side he wanted to meet up once
during my thanksgiving break freshman
year i was so nervous my hair was
sweating we met up at a park around 10
am we got his car and i realized i'm
really not cut out for this i said i had
to go to the dentist at about five
minutes away i ended up i said i had to
go to the dentist about five minutes in
and i stopped answering him after that i
was mortified who did i think i was at
least i'm not actually that weird wow
felt good to say honestly i don't think
you need to unburden yourself you did
nothing wrong your teacher's a [__]
freak and you should deadass report him
if he's still working at your school
just to be frank 100 he's the one who's
supposed to like know better and
not and good on you for getting in the
car and like getting the [__] out yeah
but i really do think you should like
anonymously report him because if he's
still working at your school he's
obviously like a freak and that's really
like not good no it's not good to have a
freak you have nothing to be ashamed of
just can't stress that enough like you
literally did nothing wrong yeah please
unver like
there's no burden to on there's no
burden to on here um but maybe think
about you know possibly
speaking to the authorities or someone i
mean it's been 10 years oh right but
maybe teachers stay at schools for a
really long time yeah it's called ten
years
so maybe you should think about speaking
to superiors yeah but again you did
literally nothing wrong no all right
next up dear jackie and claudia the last
two weeks i've been texting this guy i
met on a dating app he asked me to go
out on a date with him so he planned a
day and time to meet up he had confirmed
with me the night before that we were
still going and i told him yes the next
day he didn't text me once and honestly
i was relieved the thought of having to
take a shower do my hair and makeup then
have a conversation with someone i've
never met before was absolutely
exhausting just when i think i'm in the
clear 15 minutes before we're supposed
to meet up he texts me making sure i
know the place we're meeting at i ignore
him
i ignore him hoping that he'll just
forget about the whole thing so i don't
respond then five minutes after i was
supposed to meet him he texts me again
saying that he's there and that i should
text him once i arrive i feel absolutely
awful i call my
younger sister and she tells me at this
point i should just block his number and
forget about it because men are stupid
then i tell my mom and a couple of my
friends and they tell me i just should
have been honest i felt so so bad for
leaving at the restaurant i can just
imagine him sitting alone at the
restaurant waiting for me and it makes
me want to vomit i went to bed feeling
like a terrible person and praying that
god will forgive me all my best a
toaster who stood up her date i just
want to say um
i don't want to make you feel bad i want
to make you feel bad but i'm really
disappointed i'm like really upset for
this man
um
and i think you need to start seeking
advice from someone other than your
little sister because she's dead [__]
wrong
block him
he did nothing wrong he did nothing
wrong like because and it's just like
i don't want to make you feel bad
but
it's not good it's not good and honestly
like he's probably sitting there
wondering like did she see me and leave
like feeling so self-conscious and i
honestly think like if you really do
want to unburden yourself like you
should just send him a text and be like
i got myself into this pickle where like
i thought we weren't going out so i
couldn't shower and then you were
texting me and i was so worried like i
just think if you were honest it would
make him feel a lot better about
potentially being stood up which is just
like no one wants to feel that way
potentially being stuck
about no but like potentially thinking
like when you get stood up your worst
thought is like the person drove by saw
you and left oh i don't even i didn't
even think about that yeah so i did and
i think that's what a lot of people
assume so he's probably just like
feeling insecure so i just think if you
really wanted to like get rid of this
burden sending him a text with the truth
would be nice and maybe seeing him again
yeah but you just like i don't know what
kind of person you are and and
what not but you can't complain about
being single like ever again like that's
your approach today that's actually true
if that's your approach nice guy who
makes a plan who shows up who follows up
and
you don't then like you just want to be
single so don't go on dating no that's a
fair fair statement but i'm like we're
not here to judge no but that would be
my advice to like i think you would
actually feel a lot better if you told
him the truth and like got that off your
chest because i honestly don't think
writing into us is gonna fully uh under
the burden no like if it were me this is
something for the rest of my life every
time i thought about i would be like
cringe yeah i would have like a physical
i have a few of those yeah of course and
they do get less over the years that you
know you start go from being like to
like
to be like yeah it's
but it's still a grimace it's still a
grimace
um well i hope we made you feel better
thank you to everyone who wrote in and
unburdened themselves again if you ever
want to write in every monday we are
doing unburden yourselves at gmail.com
and also wednesdays are your toasters
and that's your toasters at gmail.com
and like i told you i told you guys
yesterday if you keep writing us
long-ass emails we're not gonna be able
to read them so if you haven't gotten
your submission read might have been
because it was too long so maybe try
reformatting it and sending it to us and
like a more broken down like just the
need to know details you need a word
count yeah um
like how many words do you think this is
because that's the perfect lane that
looks long no it's not
200 words
250 is your max
um that's our show
our show no one else's tomorrow jackie o
is back and we're doing a full mech hour
recap the looks the videos the
instagrams the selfies from the bathroom
everything
we'll be recap
i'm really excited i'm really hopeful
optimistic that we are going to get
something that is going to just like
something that we need and give us
strength inject some adrenaline to the
veins of this culture because like as a
society we're not well
truer words you've honestly never spent
more profound than that inject some
adrenaline into the veins of this
culture because as a society we are not
well no we're just like desperate and
like this it's it's actually sad like
how much pressure i'm putting on the mac
gala to make me feel something and how
disappointed we're gonna be when it is
what it always i have a low bar honestly
so like i feel like you'll be
disappointed but i'll be like this is
amazing
yeah but also it's tough with the mec
out because it's like either people are
giving nothing or they're giving like
too much and we don't understand it and
it takes years before i'm like oh that
was iconic and i missed it yeah and i
feel that
but that's our show thank you so much
for sending to the morning choice the
millennial morning show where we live in
the best live stories you need to know
every monday friday on youtube if you're
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
that's spotify itunes stitcher public
video i heard radio cast marks all the
places listen about guess what that's
more interesting leave a foster better
beautiful stunning where we are sound
like jim carrey what you sound like jim
carrey oh comedic genius thanks for the
amazing compliment the week of my
biggest show tickets available at
girlwithnojob.comtour
see you guys at madison square garden on
thursday um have a great weekend no no
no have a great day we'll see you had a
great weekend like having one for a
while yeah acknowledge the space
acknowledge his face have an amazing day
and we'll see you guys tomorrow bye